welcome back to new rockstars thanos did
nothing wrong but is every super villain
actually a super victim
according to super villains yup this
is the big question the podcast that
gives you too much information
about how good the world could be if we
just listen to some of our super
villains
a conversation that should in no way be
applied to the real world
i'm eric voss here with me is joven hey
buddy
that's right i'm taking a small break
from rogue theory to hop
on over here so the king of theories is
about to become you know the
self-proclaimed
informative villain of uh new rock stars
that's right i've got the bad guy stash
bringing you the bad guy perspective
you've gone from the king of theories to
the duke of knowledge
and you are the mayor of titles
yeah i live in a democratic society
you're still in the feudal system
um but what is our big question exactly
joven
uh our big question today is looking at
which villains
might have actually had the right train
of thought and maybe weren't as wrong as
the good guys depicted them
yes yes so who was actually right and we
should say at the beginning that uh all
well-written villains do have a
philosophy that's grounded
in reason that we're able to at least a
little bit empathize with they are just
like crazy you know there's like uh john
doe in seven
he had uh that whole rant about how
society the virtue of society is
crumbling
and you almost agree with them until you
remember oh my god
this monster kevin spacey did horrible
horrible things
and we shouldn't listen to anything if
there was only a cake in the box saying
congratulations
you caught me that villain might have
not been that bad of a guy
but there was something else in that box
what's in the box a bunch of scraps
and i think that is the key to all great
screenwriting you know when we're
watching movies they want to try to make
us feel that fleeting
devilish what if the villain is right
but then followed swiftly by moral
outrage over someone actually acting
on those dark impulses so that's we're
we're going to be dancing
with the devil tonight as nancy grace
would say the devil
is dancing tonight but of the villains
we're looking at
i don't think we're gonna be looking at
any whose motives are ethnic superiority
um sorry not sorry red skull or
voldemort
you can't really have red skull on the
list uh nazis just don't normally turn
out
never right guys never write comic arc
or real life
and uh that includes you star bellied
snitches we're not interested
in your victimhood all right uh let's
start at the top of this list the one
everyone talks about who did nothing
wrong
our man thanos uh his motive was um
according to him to save all of life
across the universe from
over consumption of resources over
population by erasing 50
of everyone uh and then when that failed
and and end game when they undid that
he came up with a new plan basically to
just tear the universe to shreds
and start fresh and with thanos i think
the biggest argument to kind of show
that he was right is
in the mcu you've got thanos as the big
bad
uh the opposite side of that spectrum is
you know the big good
which is arguably captain america and
when
captain america in his time of trying to
find the silver lining in end game
kind of realizes you know like he's he's
out there and he sees
whales coming up to the shore for the
first time and natasha's like are you
saying
he was right and he argues it but you
know you can kind of hear it in his
voice that
he's seen the positive of thanos right
again thanos wasn't like i want to
destroy half of the population
because they aren't as good as me he was
saying hey
there's not enough resources for the way
all of you guys
live and in 2020 we can't look at that
and be like
yeah no we aren't doing this the right
way at all
maybe you're on the wrong side of this
agreed yeah
when captain america the good guy of it
all can actually see the silver lining
what thanos did
i think right there that's the little
shake of him trying to like lift from
your near
where it's like all right no maybe
captain america is onto something here
yeah um agreed and tony stark would
probably argue that too i mean morgan
stark is a good example of why thanos
might have been right because from any
tragedy we can move on and
as you said jovan he was fair in his
selection he didn't
he didn't have any kind of agenda to who
he selected it was really just like a
coin flip
um and yeah let's be honest
overpopulation depletion natural
resources that's a real thing
uh that we do have to worry about um and
as we saw in endgame the avengers were
essentially doing the same thing he was
doing
it's basically a battle between who gets
to play god
and again afterwards he doesn't go and
sit on a throne of the galaxy to rule
everyone he's like
nope i'm gonna go be a farmer yeah
hey that's he sounds good this disabled
farmer who can't use his left hand or
right hand whichever it was
it's just then all of a sudden boom goes
the dynamite and there's just
superheroes in his living room
yes and then they cut off his head
finish him
fatality not fair well we should
acknowledge
why he was wrong and i think the the one
thing that everyone's kind of pointing
out since infinity war came out
is that wouldn't necessarily work
because people could just quickly
repopulate the universe
why won't he just create more planets if
you can do anything
and i and i think one thing we have to
keep in mind is thanos's whole
mission started when uh his homeworld
titan suffered this environmental
disaster
uh but he applied that logic to every
planet
and we've seen evidence in the mcu that
not every planet is headed down in this
downward spiral of ruin
look at a planet like zandar 12 billion
people on that planet
three sons scorched it but for whatever
reason they figured out their carbon
emissions no one seems to be starving on
that planet
but thanos believes that every planet is
head in that direction i don't know if
that's necessarily true
if anything this isn't a mark against
thanos i think it's a mark against you
know
blanket solutions and not one solution
will
yes be perfect for everything but
sometimes you just have to find
a balanced solution that will actually
affect
the greater good overall and i think
that's what thanos was going for
yeah uh and let's move on to our next
villain who had a similar motive
ultron i love that very few people
talked about this like this whole idea
of trying to accomplish
peace through genocide ultron's kind of
the same mission he wanted peace on
earth
by dropping sokovia on earth like a
meteor
yeah and and with ultron it kind of just
brings back like you know
the early 1900s like dilemma of like
technology where it's like
once you start to look at technology and
you give it too much power you know
maybe there's
not as much for humankind and you know
as we've progressed
it's always since the 90s it's always
been like the same bleak thing we're
like oh if
ai takes over they're gonna realize they
don't need us
right right and that's that's
essentially what ultron was he's very
similar
to agent smith in the matrix uh agent
smith who i believe had a far more
compelling and iconic monologue about
this
the idea of humanity being a virus or
disease on the planet and that's
probably how
ais like the uh like the matrix like
you know ultron would view us we are not
binary creatures we are not
uh black or white we are shades of gray
and uh
a robot can't necessarily see that but
right that being said i'm pretty sure my
roomba's out to kill me
don't put your feet on the ground not
while it's going clipping ankles
um why ultron is wrong well uh
you know robots suck and uh i think we
can all agree that mass genocide
whatever the reason is never justified
if you have to take lives to save lives
i don't care how many it was
it's not okay for that to be your plan
also going back to captain america being
like the
the big good he sees like you know one
is too many one is too many just yeah
and i hate to credit vision
because you know my thoughts on vision
but he did put it best
in that amazing final dialogue at the
end of age of ultron
humans are odd they think order and
chaos are somehow
opposites and try to control what won't
be
but there is grace in their feelings i
think you missed that but
i i think we'll see in the mc going
forward my hope jovan is that we are
still
in the age of ultron i was bummed that
he that villain was vanquished by the
end of that film
i would love it he's proven right over
time you know fans of the game uh
marvel's avengers might have
seen some uh some little hints that
maybe we don't have him in the mcu but
might be popping up in the video game
world so
we'll get some ultron love somewhere for
sure
now let's swing over to the dc world the
ultimate dc
film villain the joker from the dark
knight and yes there have been many
great jokers over the years uh but i
would say nicholson's joker and
yeah jared leto's joker are probably
more in the outright crazy category
and walking phoenix's joker while very
compelling is really more of a victim of
abuse a failing health care system
like yeah like they're really just
looking at gotham as a whole here
whereas heath ledger's joker was like no
let's look at society gotham's just an
example
yeah so his motive was to spread anarchy
throughout gotham city by taking down
the elites so that includes the cops
political leaders the crime gangs media
and of course
batman a joker himself states his
message as it's not about the money
it's about the message everything burns
and with the joker it's more of
kind of going back to a primitive state
of instinct like
what drives a human being let that
go and be what makes you happy let that
be what runs society because
when you do have any form of
organization that is led by
humans it's just gonna get turned into
greed it's gonna get turned into
corruption
yeah and you know people wearing their
masks especially
as they say absolute power corrupts
absolutely and i think that was the
joker's core mission statement
and what i love about the character in
this movie is the events of the movie in
a way
kind of prove them right you know batman
does violate civil liberties
harvey dent does go corrupt eventually
in a dark way do kind of prove joker's
points so that batman does kind of have
to become the dark knight
aside from the white knight in a way you
could say joker kind of wins that
philosophical argument despite losing it
in other ways and it's interesting
because batman is there to protect
gotham but the only ones that actually
go ahead and prove themselves against
the joker in the situation is
the boat full of criminals yeah exactly
the ordinary people
in some ways even the criminals of
society the people who have made
mistakes the flawed people
it made such an interesting statement
about that binary thing which a lot of
times batman's stories just view
criminals as like
evil or dark or messed up people who we
lock away forever what i loved about the
fairy sequence in the dark knight
is it showed that like criminal people
have the same kind of mixed perspective
of morality that
ordinary non-criminals do and that
doesn't make them people that we just
lock away and forget about forever so
yes batman can become the bad guy when
he needs to and yes
two-face takes the crep path that he
goes down but at the end of the day you
know maybe gotham can
actually fight for themselves and i
think that's the ultimate victory for
batman
the loss for joker in the film as he
pointed out he does lose that side of
the argument which you can see that
little moment that heath ledger does in
that movie where he sees that the boats
have not exploded
and he there's a little bit of panic
that the first time he looks worried
in that movie part of his plan that
didn't go according it's
such a brilliant subtle moment that i
love and i think
one thing that many people have talked
about with the joker he's
also a hypocrite which i think he's
aware of this fact but he claims to have
no plan
do i really look like a guy with a plan
yet he does more planning than anyone
like that's the joke that's the joke you
know he says he has no plans to dog
chasing cars
not at all he schemes he's rehearsing
[ __ ] in the background
so you could argue that is part of his
statement his criticism of society that
even the criminals in order to pull
these things off
are schemers who overthink things and
use people and i do want to mention that
because i feel like someone in the
comments will try to make the comparison
that we are looking at just
one of these jokers if you were to look
at all the jokers as a whole
sure more of them probably just pull way
too on one side of just being a bad guy
for the sake of being bad
whereas like another dc villain like lex
luthor
in most iterations kind of is fighting
yes for himself at times but also
be like hey this is a problem here how
do you not see the problem here
so i i think that the entire dc pool
really does
as well as the mcu when it comes to
having these diverse villains that
yeah you know maybe they aren't
completely wrong and uh speaking of
another villain from the
pages of dc comics azamandius adrian
white from
from watchmen a fascinating
philosophical villain
who many argue was in the right
in his mission so his motive was to
prevent nuclear annihilation by uniting
america in the ussr
against a perceived external threat
spoiler warning but at this point
you should know what happens here a few
decades yeah
fake giant squid teleports into the
middle of new york city
presumably from another dimension but
the whole thing is a hoax but it works
you see it in the last few pages there
when the argument with those characters
happens where it's like no you can't do
this there has to be another way
and yes even a captain america who's
saying that like one is too many of a
loss
we don't trade lives vision that's
normally just the argument there is no
solution after the argument so like even
if he was having that conversation with
ozzy mandus it'd be like all right cool
all right it's not the solution then
what is
checkmate and uh if you look at someone
like ozamandias
his noble lie sacrifices far fewer
people
three million people died with that
squid attack way less than
the people thanos killed which would
have been something like six trillion or
something like that
just on earth alone or yeah on earth
alone for ultron it would have been what
seven billion eight billion
so like three million you could imagine
uh you know just a
drop in the bucket yeah i think i am
what unites the world
more than you know a an intergalactic
threat
for sure and uh and you gotta imagine
alan moore wrote watchmen
in the middle of the 80s when you know
reagan's style of diplomacy
basically escalated everyone's fears
that we would actually have
global nuclear annihilation and that's
why you see a lot of movies war games
the terminator films came out from the
80s all these movies suddenly
oh we might actually all nuke each other
this is terrifying
the original watchmen story was uh
considered a solution to that like
are we gonna lose billions or are we
gonna lose a couple million and i think
it's just a question that is just
such a strong dilemma that i think
people will be studying that
that is it left answer right answer for
yeah
ages now if we're talking about why
osmandius was wrong the hbo watchman
does a great job looking at all those
unintended consequences years and years
later
things like conspiracy theories
superstition anxiety racism
those are all things that are
interesting because they're kind of like
a pre-world war
concerns well obviously not pre-world
war they're obvious they're throughout
history
but like back in the pre-enlightenment
days people had way more conspiracy
theories and superstition
and like fear of the other and by like
settling those nuclear things
those things come back to the force the
other things that really kind of like
pop up like it just goes to show that
there is no
ultimate peace among mankind no matter
what yeah yeah
yeah so speaking of uh peace as uh your
objective let's talk about our man steve
palpatine darth sidious the emperor from
the star wars films
very much a super villain a super
villain who just won't
die he keeps coming back no matter how
much he probably
shined he keeps coming back
why is it called the skywalker saga at
this point it just became the palpatine
saga at the end of the day
he was more than the star of that
nonology but a fascinating character to
look at though um his motive was to of
course consolidate power
in the galactic senate by
and turning it all into an empire that
he would rule the galaxy as the emperor
of that
there's villains that like thanos where
you can definitely be like
all right cool yeah you're on the right
path here i get it i've been stuck in
traffic
[Music]
too many people with the palpatine you
start to find these villains that
might have like a strong idea that maybe
like two percent of them you could be
like
okay i could see what started this but
then it just becomes like the
actions and in actions really that make
the bad guy
bad and in this case you know we're just
looking at maybe a monarchy
is it the worst way to rule a galaxy
possibly
a monarchy not bad a dictatorship
you know and then looking at using your
empire for
like slave trading and using those
slaves to kind of like boost your power
in the galaxy that seems like all right
cool the things you're doing with it
that's bad
um but you know once we get rid of the
the galactic senate and it is more of
like a monarchy there's a lot more
organization in the game it is order the
trains do run on time
is that what you're saying the
stormtroopers get to where they need to
be
i think the argument in favor of
palpatine is that the old republic
obviously wasn't really that great for
everyone there's still a lot of victims
of
war of various civil wars there were
mandalorian wars there was slavery there
was famine
the senate was super corrupt the jedi
order
was super problematic and culty they
were stealing children
stealing children or pressuring farmers
you know
pressuring farmers into handing over
their kids
as infants in some cases the galactic
senate had a lot of problems you know
lucas wanted it to be kind of an analog
for
ancient rome that's like poetry so if
they rhyme
when it had gotten really corrupt and
when uh it became an
empire as opposed to a republic but it
was not great for everyone
and the sith did have they were not the
binary
uh evil side that the jedi had made it
was the jedi order's real problem was
seeing things through those kind of
uh that dualistic frame when you're
looking at palpatine as a as a character
study i'd kind of maybe just focus on
four or five and six because that's
where you can kind of see
some motive and sure black and white
options versus you know
episode nine is uh
maybe just a smorgasbord of a movie in
the first place but maybe his
his actions afterwards not too many
people would agree with him
yeah before five and six ah i get it
four five and six i get it and i'll say
re-watching the prequels ian mcdarmid is
my favorite thing to see in in those
uh uh one two and three he's he like
there's some writing problems in those
movies but every scene he's in
you can see just that little twinkle in
his eye of how he he can
see his destiny ahead of him and how
he's just carefully working toward it
like i obviously wouldn't have worked
because that's not what the story of
star wars was but just as like a
political cautionary tale
you know in another world i would have
loved to see just the story that's
centered all around this guy
if you uh if anyone ever gets a chance
uh and i believe it is a canon story
if you read the palpatine book which
really focuses on the time leading up to
episode one and then even a little bit
of crossover you see him take darth maul
as an apprentice
you see what happens after darth maul
gets sent to naboo um and and you just
see his story and you know who he was
looking up to at the time
darth plagueis is not a canon story
anymore but
i believe it was the same author that
did both and there are some stuff from
the plagueis story that gets brought
into the palpatine book
making those at least uh those jacks
become but uh we gotta say
why palpatine is wrong because imperfect
democracy
despite how imperfect it is is better
than
fascism and i'm going to repeat that for
all of our
voters in a couple weeks imperfect
democracy
is better than fascism imperfect
do not let the perfect be the enemy of
the good imperfect is okay
[Music]
there is no perfect sound yes absolutely
and
if you look at palpatine who was in some
ways based on hitler the
you know the empire is based on their
space nazis
and like a lot of fascist dictators
palpatine calls for
things like peace law and order but
really those are insincere fronts for
his own narcissism and his own selfish
desires to cling to power
um and as you said jovan a a monarchy
isn't the worst thing in the world there
was a lot of absolute monarchs
throughout history
who were very merciful and they did a
lot to advance
their own nations domestically uh
monarchs like elizabeth the first
louis xiv they were not perfect people
but they did a lot
to do ultimate good for the world
yeah um but palpatine isn't interested
in that he really
is an emperor and he reinforces that
with constant war
and that war makes the lives of ordinary
people worse
so that's that's ultimately how he
should be judged
um all right let's get back to the mcu
we have a couple more on our list talk
about our man
killmonger from black panther i think uh
when you look at thanos is like the
go-to answer i think um
uh even just look at social media which
is you know a social representation of
of humans on twitter after the whole
thanos thing so you had hashtag thanos
is right and then you also had hashtag
killmonger is right
no he's definitely going back uh as i
said earlier an example of
yes what you your argument is true
it is your mindset that is incorrect
what would society look like
if wakanda didn't just close itself up
off from the world with that technology
um would we have the systemic racism
that we have dealt with for hundreds of
years now
right probably not yeah it's one thing
to identify a problem it's another to
know what solution
to apply to that problem and uh the
reason as you say killmonger resonate
with so many people is that that whole
idea of like redistributing
like wealth and redistributing power
to the oppressed people around the world
to spark this revolution
is an honorable noble pursuit
the the problem is is that putting guns
in the hands of more people is never a
good idea
more guns always make things worse
you're going down
the wrong path and again for killmonger
where you really started to get a little
whether it was bad writing or just
shades of gray of the character it
wasn't necessarily
a motive in race because he was killing
people that were also black
and just because they were standing in
his way there was a little moment where
uh he said there were war dogs standing
by in new york london and hong kong and
i assume those war dogs were military
commanders
who were gonna try to like go and rally
troops for this global revolution
but like i wish that they had just shown
us one scene to show who those war dogs
were
if they were like educators community
organizers
social workers that would have been
awesome to be like
oh yes war will be part of it but really
we're just organizing people to build a
new society
that would have been a very different
conversation good you know we look at
the
what if of of marvel like what if
wakanda didn't
put up its walls against the rest of the
world the horrible past of
england going to africa and seeing these
people there that were
not as they were more primitive and so
they they're like all right we will use
these people because they are not as
high in society as us
by giving all the technology that
wakanda had uh
maybe the story would have been
literally flipped maybe people from
africa would have actually grown to be a
stronger society and then moved out to
the rest of the world to see these
savages where it's like people in
england's like
what are you doing still drinking tea
and shooting muskets what
you're gonna work for us now and for no
pay yeah one thing that was really great
about the conclusion of black panther is
that t'challa grows and he learns like
he
he gets mad at his own ancestors for
denying and erasing that history
and he he learned something from
killmonger and that
we do have a responsibility to
lift up everyone else and that's the
solution he pulls he ends up pulling the
right solution which
the the the way we change the world
revolution is important and can be
justified
but like the real revolution is working
within the system to
to change things do more outreach and
education yeah and that's
wonderfully what uh t'challa and shuri
do in that final scene they're back in
oakland
and it's it's why that movie was just so
important as a as a society and as
yeah to our culture as well like that's
it wasn't a superhero
it was a superhero movie but it had an
impact that i think really spoke to a
lot of people in a lot of races
yeah so i i think killmonger wasn't
necessarily wrong he was just wrong and
his fix to the problem
but one character one super villain in
the marvel universe that i think
was absolutely right it's just had a
slightly incorrect approach to it
was hella hella of course wanted to
reclaim the asgard
throne that was hers to claim
if you're gonna have a monarchy you
gotta follow the rules if you're next in
line you're next in line yep
and she was odin's firstborn that throne
belonged to her
odin banished her and erased her from
history now we don't know the full story
there
only her side of the story but it looks
like she essentially showed the same
blood thirst
that thor was showing thor got banished
to new mexico
another she got banished to
hell you're all going to hell goodbye
so it's like there was a double standard
odin was not one's worse
really and i would say
why she was most right is look at the
the grand
context of the marvel universe at that
moment
asgard after odin desperately needed a
strong ruler
to protect all the realms from the
threat of thanos
[Music]
because asgard was not there you could
argue that's what led to the infinity
war
yeah if um if hello was kind of like
running the show there maybe keeping
whatever infinity stones
check like would thanos have been able
to invade and take over
yeah it would have been tough the really
the problem with hela is that she has
zero diplomacy zero
like the moment she meets anyone any of
her subjects she smugly attacks them if
they don't immediately kneel
it's kind of got this cersei energy to
her uh there's no evidence
based on this that she would be a good
queen for asgard because a good monarch
knows how to be diplomatic
and knows when to swing the sword living
by fear is not a great answer
in fairness to her she was cruelly
banished and that probably made her a
bit vengeful
but if she could have just put that
vengeance aside yeah it's
you know banishing her way and working
with her and communicating but you know
that's just the uh
the the leftist in me i guess no it's a
human in you these things shouldn't be
politicized cooperation should be
bipartisan
yes yes
[Music]
ultimately the movies themes kind of
make hella wrong because the ultimate
theme of ragnarok is everything has to
come to an end and we have to learn to
accept death and learn when to let go
and to move on and you know asgard's not
a place it's a people and
hella stands directly in contradiction
to those themes but
in her own context i would argue that
you know maybe she needed to project
confidence had no reason to apologize
asgard needed a strong warrior queen
needed a united loyal citizenry for the
wars ahead
but uh unfortunately i don't know if
that would have been effective because
she just really sucks at winning hearts
and minds
and will valkyrie really be the leader
that
new asgard needs what will valkyrie
learn from hella's mistakes the way
t'challa learned from killmonger's
mistakes
oh yeah oh yeah it's all coming together
so we'll see for now we want to move on
to some people who helped us make this
episode
first of all forensic horse light these
days a lot of us are stuck
indoors with the closest we get to an
escape cracking open a mountain cold
refreshment of a coors light
the beer that is cold lagered cold
filtered and cold packaged just
literally
made to chill it's as crisp and
refreshing as the colorado rockies
perfect for a moment to unwind and
everything that comes from colorado
is good so oh yeah yeah it's it's just a
natural wonderful thing
coors light wants to give you a way to
take a break from the new reality of
endless video chats in 2020 we're all
living in this
world let's have a bit of a break from
that say goodbye to your video chat
background and
hello to that new beautiful travel
destination in real life
and actually chill so here's one thing
that they're offering five lucky winners
will get trips to the beautiful
destinations they've been dreaming about
going to for months
to enter for a chance to win visit
coorslight.com outside
during september and upload a screenshot
of yourself in your ideal video chat
background
the prize package is valid through june
2022
so winners can plan their trip for
whenever they feel comfortable to go on
it
personally i have really been wanting to
go do like a month-long trip
in australia in new zealand uh and
that's something that like
we have some friends who are moving to
australia right now um but
we i you know we've always wanted to go
visit that place i want to go to middle
earth
i want to go to melbourne in sydney i
want to go to the outback i would
go to the great barrier reef but like
because australia and new zealand are
you know much further along than we are
we're not allowed to go into those
countries but that would be my dream
destination sometimes i'll use the
sydney opera house as the background of
my uh uh
of my zoom calls so this could be my
chance if i winter to go there
i want to know where you want to go
think about this enter this
uh you can enter a chance to win a trip
to the beautiful destination of your
choice at coorslight.com
outside celebrate responsibly coors
brewing company golden colorado no burst
is necessary sweepstakes begin on august
27th 2020 ends on october 1st 2020. open
only to legal residents of the 50 states
and district of columbia
20 years of age or older travel must be
to the destination indicated in the
entry
and must be completed by june 30th 2022
for official rules
including how to enterprise details and
restrictions visit www.courselife.com
outside void where prohibited message
and data rates may apply
we also want to thank our friends at
full sail university for sponsoring this
episode working in the film industry is
an exciting and rewarding experience
if you know you want to be a part of it
but don't know where to begin you really
should check out full sail university
where you can learn all aspects
of filmmaking and cinematography either
on campus or online
uh it's in florida that's where i'm from
i had a lot of friends who went to full
sail university and now that i'm in la i
keep running into people
who have amazing industry jobs and in
all aspects of the industry
do i find out hey you went to full sail
too there's something about this place
so full sales film bachelor's degree
program immerses you in the world of
filmmaking from every angle you'll gain
hands-on experience while learning what
it's like to work on a large-scale
production from start to finish
giving you a feel for the role each crew
member plays and allowing you to zoom in
on the areas
where your strengths and interest lay oh
and speaking of zoom in the digital
cinematography online bachelor's degree
program
merges the artistic concepts of
traditional filmmaking with the
technical tools used in
everything from documentary filmmaking
to commercial production and web video
preparing you to be a jack of all trades
and small crew productions
which that's how a lot of things are
happening right now the very small crews
it helps to know a lot of different
aspects of production
uh when you're working on those things
when you're first getting started
especially
these degrees are offered in an
accelerated format to get you
into the field faster with hands-on
projects industry experience faculty
and professional equipment and sets
you'll be prepared to pursue your
passion
full sail grads i've gone on to work on
things like game of thrones adventures
in game the mandalorian just to name a
few and
yeah that that's very true there's every
show
and the production i've worked on
there's probably someone from full sail
or someone who knows from full sail
so it's a great networking community to
know as well so if you want to find out
more about these film programs and how
to get started visit
fullsail.edu slash bigquestion that's
fullsale.edu
bigquestion and now we're going to go on
to some little bite size questions that
joven's going to answer for us are you
ready man i love answering questions
all right so first is our friend that
mcu guy on discord who asked
in titanic could both jack and rose have
fit on that door i love talking about
this one
uh yes and i always like to go back to
the mythbusters episode right now that's
right it's not the size of the door that
mattered but it was actually the boy
motion of the ocean
[Music]
so yes they could have fit on there i i
do believe
i remember seeing a drawing that james
cameron himself
did when he got tired of the argument
saying that
no it doesn't work look at this drawing
look at this drawing look at
this drawing look at this photograph i
think that maybe they could have done a
little
uh okay i'm on it right now and now
you're on it now i'm on it now you're on
it yeah did the mythbusters guys like
they they rotated
and they uh used the light preserver and
tied it underneath to give it extra
buoyancy
which is smart i wonder if the i'm sure
they're also very accurate in
in their findings but if it was
wide enough to make it around the door
because that is a large
area to kind of cover and if uh you know
their life preservers were as well made
as you know uh even
ones made in the last 50 years well it
looks like what they did is they took
off some of the straps and they used
that
to they tried to sheep shank and they
tied it around
to make it to extension which is really
hard to do when you've just gone through
the traumatic experience of you know
losing a boat i'm on a boat
[Music]
and if you're not an engineer if you're
already freaking out
you know those guys are practical they
would think of that because we're smart
i don't know if jack and rose would and
to answer your question easily
yes they both could have fit but then
the boat would have sank and they both
would've been in the water and frozen
to death yeah chances are both of them
would have died
uh and hey for the story as james
cameron says in that mythbusters episode
because he was a guest on it
and he looks so pissed when they're like
uh
they both gonna fit he's like really
he's like so salty
but like as he points out hey jack needs
to die in the story for it to be
a good story the dude's going down can't
argue with that no down down
down down maybe captain america wouldn't
agree but you know
yeah all right also our friend
ninjachris82
on twitter asks how do the ninja turtles
get money for their pizza
um i i think in today's age there are so
many different ways to make money
where being in public isn't necessary um
have you met 2020 are you okay
yeah so okay i i i like to live in a
world where you know
at at night three of the turtles are
actually going out and scavenging the
trash that's maybe in the sewers or just
being put in dumpsters
and they're maybe old technology
bringing it back to donny
he's fixing it up they're selling it on
ebay for a price yeah sure
there's plenty of money to be made um
uh there are examples through the comics
and then the cartoons where
you know they actually have found other
ways to to get work
and and to be able to pay stuff on the
side michelangelo as a
birthday party clown of sorts um
donatello we saw in a movie was doing
tech support
so there's money to be made don't look
so far into it hey
and you know everyone's money floats
down to the sewer eventually
[Music]
every time i get paid i just throw it
right into the sewer i'm like that's
the turtles yep yep uh and they could
hit up april you know
the tv reporters just making enough
money for pizza yeah
all right we are now going to move on to
our mailbag question a little segment we
like to call
pulling questions from the box scraps
and uh jovan our question this week is
from twitter user omni wang
uh who asks have you ever had to mute
yourself on camera because you had to
fart
which now that i read it might refer to
like zoom calls which
is something i've done but we're going
to rephrase it to this question if you
have a story about this joven go
go ahead but we're going to ask what's
the funniest reason you had to stop in
the middle of a recording
of anything you know to to kind of merge
both of those together in one answer uh
very embarrassing
uh shoot we uh it was with the old
youtube channel that i was a part of we
actually had
two guests from germany they they were
like the two top
german youtubers and they were gronk and
zalazar and they were with us
and before shooting we decided to take
them to gyukaku they've never heard of
it before they've never done it before
you know
barbecue your own meat so there i am
having a good time drinking eating some
food
um maybe i didn't cook all of my food as
thoroughly as i probably should have and
so afterwards while filming with them in
a very small
enclosed space with no ventilation uh
no windows that opened i thought oh no
something's coming
i'll just let it sneak out quietly no
it's never quiet well this one was i'm
the master of the silence
uh but it it had more of a lasting
effect than i thought it would and when
you watch this video you can see my cast
member kind of look at me
it's like did you do that we didn't cut
the audio
because i don't just like just let it go
just just keep moving on keep it right
it only filled up the entire room and it
might have been the worst smell that
these guys have ever smelled in the life
of because even if we wanted to be
professional carry on
they had to be like what is that smell
that's way to stop production to open
doors take a little break outside of the
room to let it all air out
uh it happens don't eat gukaku before uh
before filming with guests it's not
that's the thing jovan and i understand
this but when you are shooting uh
any kind of streaming content whether
it's like podcasting or youtube videos
you always find the most like uh closed
off room
in the studio or wherever you are no
windows you know no
audio great yeah you need it for the
audio
yep yep and that's one benefit of now
being uh
separated from each other as we're all
in our own little dungeons and we can
fart it up if we want to press the mute
button it's helpful
i have had to and zoom calls press the
mute button when i'm about to sneeze
really bad but people can always see me
like duck my head off camera
it's never good um there was a time
in there was a time in in college we
were shooting like a sketch
where uh my buddy tito had to get uh
fake hit by a car he was like a
political candidate who was trying to do
some like campaigning in a neighborhood
he tried to run across a busy street to
talk to a voter and then we like
we did some visual effect where it
looked like a car was about to hit him
and then we did like cut two two minutes
later and we had him on the ground like
all bloodied up like in the middle of
our neighborhood street
uh because when you're in florida you
can just shoot wherever you want and no
one cares
but like yeah people saw this bloody guy
laying in the ground with
a bunch of people around him with phones
recording him so
someone called the cops and in
gainesville florida cops are
everywhere i think cops outnumber
civilians in gainesville
because they always uh it was like a
game day weekend stories i feel like
they need some extra help they
definitely do need the help especially
if it's a game day weekend in
gainesville florida
you know the population increases by
like a hundred thousand and they're all
there
to get drunk and beat each other up so
cops aren't
necessarily needed but this cop was like
what and then drove by
and uh so the cop pulled up and he's
like is he okay
and then all i said was like oh it's
it's for
a um it's for a short film we're doing
and immediately the cup was like all
right cool bye
bye so we did have to like stop all of
our production for a second be like oh
we have to explain to this police
policeman
what is going on we have like the one
producer that's on set that's supposed
to just distract the cop
long enough for us to get our shot
before then having to shut everything
down
it's crazy how production works it
really is just like having pas having
producers
having assistant directors who are just
there just to stall the world for like
you know 20 minutes just so we can get a
shot because like permits yeah if you're
a professional film crew you get a
permit
but even then you have onlookers you
have people who are honking their horns
serve cops who do don't understand
what's going on
and they're like what they're someone's
jumping off a building
you see if you can push it to do a
little bit right while you're there
yeah it's uh it's a lot of asking for
forgiveness not permission
uh but we'd even have to i just love
that that cop did not care he's just
like ah
that's fine i think my tito was like and
the cop was like i don't want to deal
with these
these stupid college students who aren't
actually drunk or fighting some nerds
who are rather on a game day pre-gaming
they're shooting a sketch nerds
yeah it really was one of those um
but hey we were grateful for that
because like for a second all of our
hearts stopped like oh god we're gonna
get arrested
well that is this week's show jovan it
was awesome having you on this episode
of big question talking about super
villains who
were very super and probably still a
little villainous but not that villain
yeah
and let's be let's be very clear that
when we're talking about villains
sometimes you really have to stretch the
theme to kind of find the good in them
but i think that also is what makes a
good villain uh don't
don't tweet me the hate mail if you will
i don't think that palpatine was right
yes and again this is a conversation
that should not be applied to the real
world
i don't want you playing devil's
advocate for any actual real world
devils
okay but it's okay to give people who
are purple the benefit of the doubt
sometimes
a reminder that you can join our
official discord by going to patreon at
patreon.comrockstars you can get an
audio version of the show by subscribing
to rockstar's big question wherever you
get your podcasts
thanks to everyone who submitted
questions this week we had some really
great questions
uh and you could send us your big
questions on twitter using the hashtag
bigquestion
but again you we're gonna see it most
clearly and quickly
if you join our discord because we
always check there first uh you can
follow me at eavos follow joven
at the joke and shire there it is yep
yeah and follow new rockstars and
socials and subscribe here on youtube
you get too much information on all the
stuff you care about
see you next week everybody thanks joven
bye guys
you